the episode's credits credit to vincent
d'onofrio yes i know yeah all right i
guess at some point coy judd and i were
talking to each other looking
and then the name came on screen and
then we spent the whole credits
discussing how his name didn't come on
screen really showed up twice many of
you guys went way out of your way to
tell us in the comments and then also
to
uh hit me up on social media some of you
tracked out my home knocked on my door
what do you guys keep it down out there
we all
know we get it thank you
there was no need to set my car on fire
and then put in fire words like batman
that fits into it
[Music]
well hello there reject nation we're
here today to show off our epic hero
shops
hey
swag am i right hawkeye episode 5
breakdown in easter eggs from nr today
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of hawkeye
episode 5 ronin which confirms kingpin
as the mcu's mr grinch whose heart only
grows three sizes when he needs a rush
of blood too
throw a trust a bro truck
so let us break it all down scene by
scene for everything that you might have
missed the episode opens with some
familiar audio all moments from the
black widow film the opening sound
effect was the same sound of the moment
the antidote spray hit elena and woke
her up from her programming
[Music]
then elena explained
synthetic wow it's a synthetic gas the
counter agent to chemical subjugation
eta antidote control
then attached at the end of the movie
handing the elaine to that list of
widows and the antidote he had widows
that planted all over the world
you should be the one to tell them it's
over we had widows that planted all over
the world
molina will need to copy the formula but
you should be the one to tom it's over
and then this whistle
this was how the sisters signal each
other right
that's the sound we make when a new
rockstars video is out huh
time to react
but this precise whistle audio was
actually elena at natasha's grave in the
post-credits scene
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now this opening scene of hawkeye
episode 5 is set in 2018 so that makes
the elena's final whistle here come in
from a future moment after natasha's
death so all of this is echoing through
time as kang explained time is happening
all at once flat circle yada yada yada
yada now the mountain
the opening shot almost looks
monochromatic like a black and white
throwback to an older era but also a
hint to the monochromatic dust that
elena will soon transform in and out of
this mountain range also kind of looks
like sokovia age of ultron did use the
real-life aosta valley in the italian
alps their target anna could have
profited from the chaos in that region
following the avengers battle there
elena is packing the white tactical gear
that she was wearing at the end of black
widow but she's got a new vest since she
gave her old ones
sonia who's not in black widow in the
music in these opening moments and
really throughout the episode is lauren
balf's black widow score
on a flings a t-plate at yelena elena
does not even flinch as it zips past her
face my question is why did anna throw
the plate intentionally at the wall
and not on her face if she felt she was
really being threatened in some way she
clearly gets into a fight with them it
didn't make sense to me it still
distracts me was it intentional cause
she wouldn't miss the way she'd miss no
no
yeah there's gotta be some deeper
meaning that will be revealed in like
hawkeye season four when i walked into
this reaction i was expecting vos to
explain to me not that elena didn't
flinch but why anna is so terrible at
plate frisbee that's what i wanted to
know
and uh
yeah just gotta say i'm gonna return
these shirts now geez voss come on
dropping the ball but the antidote is
ineffective i don't think she was
brainwashed what you thought i was some
rich perverts prisoner she's referring
to drakov who creepily programmed his
widows but also telling us that anna was
totally aware that dracop was doing that
to the other widows of course this being
2018 should have been a clue to you that
this would either be post snap or snap
imminent confirmed as the elena goes
into the bathroom and finds water
running through her disintegrated hands
and it's such an affecting sequence that
the directors burton bertie unfold in 60
seconds of unbroken camera movement
recalling the similar chaos of monica
rambo's blip return in one division but
they're super clever with the blocking
if you look closely elena shuts the door
on her way in but somehow the camera
glides in with her without getting
bumped by the door and then on the other
side of the blip the door is now back
open as it would be in a house five
years later with no one in there lucky
for elena that was the case but i think
they actually vfx that door and sold it
being there with that shutting door
sound effect all to pull this off as a
private moment while still allowing for
more fluid camera movement you might be
right holy crap hold on a second watch
the door look at the door in the handle
look at the doorknob right here that's
the doorknob watch it keep watching
huh is that because she shifted and is
now blocking the light that was
reflecting off of that or is that a cgi
defect did the doorknob just actually
dropped out of now look the shot goes on
for shock goes on for a while before she
blips before she puts her hand in the
water you oh well it's in time with her
shift though what shift
her body is moving
she moves to the left and then the light
she's got the light above her head here
no other light is changing though no no
but i'm saying she could be like
obscuring the light from reflecting onto
the door handle or it's a goof and some
cgi artist should be fired
i feel like there's no other shadow so
it makes it was weird to me that only
the doorknob would be shadowed then
let's go with that i think you're
probably right
i'm gonna say stuck on this because by
doing this all in one take it plants us
inside of yelena's point of view showing
us how for snap victims this was a quick
confusing transition they didn't even
blackout or faint for them time passed
instantaneously and their worlds around
them shifted and unlike the characters
we saw dust in infinity war elena
doesn't seem to feel it happening maybe
since she is always living with a sense
of unease and physiological detachment
and then even after elena completes her
own dust transition from her perspective
the surfaces of the bathroom the color
of the walls the mirror framing
it's such an interesting way to show the
passage of time in this instant with
reality reconfiguring piecemeal also
evoking the way reality warps due to
wanda max monk's witchcraft and venom's
transference into the mcu this all just
feels like reality stone based reality
manipulation this in the mcu is what it
looks like when characters are
transported in and out of reality this
really effective moment i mean i think
the way they've they've established the
blip is that it can affect you in
different cases like if you're asleep
like monica rambo if you're someone who
has healing abilities like how
spider-man that's what took him a little
bit longer to blip but then you see
other characters who can feel
something's going on with them in
infinity war but then there's others who
don't seem aware like like even with
chadwick boseman and when he before he
says bye to okoye it doesn't look like
he's sensing that something's about to
happen to him it's kind of subjective
towards the character or perhaps just
the mood of the effect they want for the
filmmaking moment it's more likely what
i think it's going to be it's probably a
little bit easier i like how anna's new
daughter plays on a little schroeder
piano beside her husband and anna says
they adopted which is a painful reminder
that these widow assassins are unable to
bear children from forced hysterectomies
also maybe this girl could have been an
orphan from parents who dusted if so
that would be a bummer custody battle i
like how anna remains all about that
mercenary life because despite all the
little family cosmetic changes she's
made at the home she still keeps up that
mural that depicts a boar hunt meaning
that in her heart she is still a hunter
as the elena still feels she must be
kate bishop returns to her childhood
bedroom which i gotta say despite being
destroyed along with the rest of that
house in 2012 now looks to be fully
reassembled and left this way for kate
kate now has a hawkeye poster on her
wall and eleanor tells her it just means
that what you do might look a little
different than you dreamed of as a child
and preferably the littlest reckless
ever wanted to be reckless i just wanted
to help you i know hon
recklessness is the unfortunate side
effect just another example of how
eleanor groomed her daughter to expose
her to danger this is not a normal
mother-daughter relationship similarly
based on lies there's the relationship
between qazi and maya qazi nurses her
wounds the same way eleanor did kate's
these are the scars from the elena's
widow's bites that latched onto maya's
chest last episode kazi though only
wants maya to stop pursuing the ronin to
keep his betrayal of her father a secret
meanwhile elena finds kate back at her
home
[Music]
oh
hi
she's mac and cheese mac and cheese
being elena's dinner pick when she was a
kid in black widow i want mac and cheese
oh you want mac and cheese okay well we
have to wonder if elena ever really
intended to heat it up with all that
sriracha she might have just dumped it
all on after kate threw it at her like
some kind of hot ones alpha mind
drink i games it up elena wears a
similar yellow and black outfit that she
wore in the black widow post credit
scene and once again she has a number of
pins on her lapel in this scene you can
get a spider maybe for her black widow
history finger guns maybe a nod to her
wrist based widow bites in a margarito
glass cause the girl drinks she's an
alcoholic i'm not going to hurt you
i promise
i don't have any weapons on me
okay i take that back i don't have any
weapons currently in my hands that's a
lie also yeah elena is totally playing
games from the moment their interaction
begins she knows that rolling up her
sleeves she's gonna reveal to kate her
widow's bites and that's because this
whole friendly chat is really an
interrogation in order to threaten kate
and learn clint's location but elena
takes her time she says come on take a
fork eat
eat please my daddy says it's good for
you of course referring to the big
appetite of alexi shostakov who forced
her and natasha to dine with them in
order to make peace and then elena tells
kate well
it's my first time in new york but i do
want to see some things i want to see uh
the empire state building the new and
improved statue of liberty
the new and improved statue of liberty
of course referring to the remodeled
lady liberty that we see in spider-man
no way home with a giant captain america
shield and her green oxidation restored
to her original copper color with the
rogers musical billboard and the no way
home promo clip marvel studios wants to
make it clear that these events are in
the same city in the same era of mcu
history see that that's where i actually
had some questions though it raised some
real [ __ ] eyebrows
as you see here in the promo footage for
spider-man no way home the statue of
liberty is under construction i know
that broadway shows they can run for a
very long period of time they last
longer than film playing in a movie
theater so i get that whether it be
rogers the musical billboards around
still it still is what time frame is
this on spider-man no way home does take
place um around the winter time you can
presume that maybe this is intersecting
around the same time but no one's gonna
see the statue of liberty when it's
under construction like you can't see it
right or am i wrong about that am i
wrong tell me if i'm wrong if i'm wrong
i'll admit i'm wrong but i don't think
i'm wrong it's the thing john i think
i'm wrong
i think you're not wrong
so why are you hearing me i don't think
that door knob is fake just so you know
i think that jordan is probably fake
this conversation proves it
yeah i feel like if you were fixing a
giant piece to the top of it
and all the scaffolding i mean yeah like
certain things remain open under
construction but i feel like having such
a big hazardous piece and also
deoxidizing the outside i feel like they
would have to kind of close it for a
little while you can't have tourists
come by
probably pretty dangerous
they wouldn't unveil their newly
designed stats as tourist attraction
like still got months ahead
she also mentions rockefeller center
reminding us that the finale episode
will take place at 30 rock the nakatomi
tower in this die hard homage then elena
gushes about christmas i love american
christmases the tree
the presents the super powered reindeer
rudolph mm-hmm
he's so weird
right here rudolph again elena is plain
nice but to her remember christmas is a
dark lie as we learn in black widow
their spy family would stage opening
empty christmas presents for fake family
photos in home movies but for young
elena she bought into that lie and it
was real to her and then elena begins to
show her cards sometimes you're funny
kid bishop do you keep saying my whole
name just to point out that you know it
yes
i know a lot about you yeah this
interrogation is so well structured it's
a lot like hans landa wearing down that
told you and in glorious bastards
that was the exact reference we made we
said it's like what you said milk scene
what milk what milk no that's i don't
know milk oh i thought you were
sarcastically being like i told you that
i named the scene you named what milk
scene this one yeah that's the milk yeah
yeah so you said it was like a tarantino
yeah
we did it we did it eric voss is
watching our [ __ ]
missing details and picking them up
weeks
right there in the moment watch our
video back
i'm not going to take the time to insert
it here
the pleasantries lead to the hunter's
reputation and then the hunter having
actually done their homework until
finally the hunter just lays it all out
are you in new york to talk to clint is
that why you're here no no no no no no
i'm here to kill him
and then elena finally arrives no mr
bundy i expect you did that he needs to
ask kate so
where is he
i don't know
okay
yes after all that lecturing cade about
how we are defined by our actions not by
flashy words like hero or avenger loren
valve's black widow theme returns here
framing both of these women as soon to
be deconstructed versions of the heroes
that they once worshipped meanwhile
clint does the same that i did after
getting mephisto wrong
florence pew is so good i'm so great so
grillz lets clint crash with him missy
dropped off the new outfits for you and
kate you wanna see him yeah missy is
that larper leader from past episodes it
sounds like she stitched some new
matching suits for clint and kate that
will get revealed in next week's finale
meanwhile eleanor called the cops on
jack it seems these are detectives
coddle and rivera we actually saw
detective coddle back in episode oh yeah
that eleanor hired this guy didn't pick
that up cop in the comics both these
characters are lapd detectives but as
jackets cuffed he says i'm telling you
the only sloane i've ever known was this
woman i did it in palm beach and she was
an absolute nightmare yeah it's hard to
get a read on exactly what's going on
here because it does seem like jack is
putting on some kind of performance like
this is all set up so that jack would be
taken away the moment kate walked in
through the door and it seems like it
was a show to temporarily stop kate from
pursuing this that's what i was thinking
i firmly believe it's an act okay here's
where i'm a little bit suspicious is
that
i'm like why would you just bring in
jack ducain from the comics who is such
a big part of hawkeye specifically yes
it's obviously not going to borrow the
origin story that is linked to clint
barton he's still such a big character
they tease that he's a swordsman no it's
got there's got to be something more to
him and this seems like another mislead
before the finale that this was all some
big ploy to throw clint and kate off the
of the scent of them right but then i'm
like this is also the mcu which has
given us trevor slattery ralph boner
[ __ ] ass version okazi which some of
you guys are defending okay maybe it is
just that and the the whole point was to
make you go ah he's a villain no he's
not uh well i'm like well that's the
most predictable part of this is that
eleanor is really a baddie yeah yeah
absolutely i mean i i feel like you
could make something interesting out of
it if it is truly okay jack and eleanor
are working together on this that's why
jack is so unfazed and maybe there's
more going on
you know than just like hey you know
jack's just being slimy so clint visits
a battle in new york memorial that's on
the bridge that leads to grand central
in pershing square this is the exact
spot where the six of them first teamed
up in the iconic circle shot in avengers
and clint removes his hearing aid when
he talks to natasha in order to silence
the world around him which is so sweet
when you consider all the other times
that he silenced everything on this
series now we know so that he could be
alone with his thoughts about natasha
and he tells her you always had to win
didn't you
and for a stupid one also silence during
the play of natasha's
sacrificing herself to acquire that that
left clint one second holding natasha in
his hand to the next second holding this
stupid orange rock in his hand he also
says i replayed that a million times in
my head hoping for a different outcome
recalling how dr strange played through
over 14 million different outcomes but
only one victorious one that still
required the sacrifice of a fellow
avenger now among kate's trophies and
medals in her room is a photo of her and
her father derek hiking reminding us
that there's still a mystery to that guy
that we have yet to know also a daring
which might be why she suggested
boomerang arrows to clint last week then
on our bulletin board is a magazine page
of clint with the words hero worship and
then on the left a ticket for the bishop
security holiday party december 21.
wow a good detail
in the finale then the track suits ivan
and tomas listen to some holiday jams
this is run dmc's christmas and hollis
it's another omasha die hard when argyle
plays it while driving mclean to
nakatomi plaza tomas runs through some
other famous tracksuit wearers and pop
culture tommy smith was the olympic
track runner who gave the black power
salute to the 68 games he also mentions
the royal tenenbaums referring to ben
steller and his two kids in the west
anderson film and of course tony soprano
hey forget about it and this is going to
be totally rooting into the wordplay
here but they debate whether or not they
themselves are royal tenenbaums and in
german tannenbaum is christmas tree in
episode three we saw a bunch of
christmas trees getting stuck to these
bozos so not intentional i i just like
seeing patterns they both have christmas
tree powers you
don't ever
ever
downplay any
theory at all do you stay strong on all
of them out of thousands of theories
everyone seemed to get kane the
conqueror right so every theory is
plausible including yours mr vos
[Music]
boss vos that's how you get to be the
boss is you gotta treat every theory
with the utmost credence because you
never know which one's gonna be the one
don't ever let a theory of vos just get
tossed nah it's your loss
have we heard of the actress kate moss
in a while i would be crossed if she
were to retire darren clint calls his
wife she's got her hands on the watch
she looked into her family glenn we've
been so careful really and the kids and
i are so far away if i don't end this
tonight it's just a matter of time
before the big guy gets involved jesus
are you sure yeah still no firm answers
on what exactly that avengers rolex is
all about it could be linked with nick
fury and have a scroll asset list could
bring in the x-men or it could be the
property of phil coulson who did wear
rolexes as we've seen in past films and
this show could confirm as him still
being alive which would officially
canonize agents of shield in the mail do
but ultimately it does sound like the
bartons are in some kind of government
except for danny ramsey and that laura
was also part of that life of spycraft
so it's still possible that she could be
an ex-mockingbird but we'll find out
next week i somehow feel like there's
not going to be a really big payoff to
that watch i feel like probably right
i feel like there are probably a few big
threads that aren't going to amount to
too much
i also think the watch belongs to all
four members of the fantastic four
yeah
and then sometimes doctor doom gets tab
flint lures maya to the fat man used car
lot the same auto shop where he killed
her father and notice how the camera
focuses on that fat man part of the sign
another reminder that the tracksuits
probably name this front after their
boss maya and clint fight she throws a
bullet clip at him i love that each time
the sword strikes her prosthetic leg it
makes a nice ping sound
no larper folding nice scary clint
reveals that he was the ronin who killed
her father after he was tipped off by an
informant in their ranks that was
approved by their boss aka uncle aka
kingpin and he says that both of them
are really weapons being manipulated by
bigger power players in the shadows and
as maya leaves the neon sign shines used
as she must feel in this moment wow
get away hey are you tabitha yes it's
unrelated
was the name of mr harrington's wife who
faked her dusting to leave him one of my
favorite random subjects oh that's right
so i guess you could see this as a kind
of name for mcu women trying to flee
under false
who pretenses off the ronin and led to
william's death but she doesn't act on
it yet
maya's gonna kill kazzy
kate tells clint i tricked her she said
she's natasha
tasha's past with her spy family was a
total secret to pretty much everyone she
did tell clint about her which makes
sense considering she knew about his
secret family i just like knowing how
much these two characters knew about
each other and loved each other and then
after they get dropped off clint gives
kate an arrow remember eleanor gave kate
her first bow and now clint gives her
the arrow i think that was the one that
she used to knock the sword out of
maya's hands in order to save his life
making this a kind of token that their
mentor apprentice relationship is
restored i gotta say those are like my
favorite moments of the show those
little subtle touches between clint and
kate yeah and watching them walk off
like some indie drama and eating up the
arrow like crime fighters in the streets
just
who don't have like the high classy
modes of transportation
who got to walk home feeling battered
and bruised yeah we're just sharing this
quiet moment together there's great body
language great bodies too great bodies
man where's that
2022 calendar now just be clear this is
not lot palace hotel where eleanor's
charity event was held in episode 1
which was the same location as kingpin's
presidential hotel residents in
daredevil season 3. we don't know what
this building is yet but notice that
elena looks up at the building and seems
to register something about it meaning
this might be the mcu's disk tower now
we are still waiting to see who the
avengers tower was sold to tom holland
signaled that he knew who but i have not
yet seen spiderman no way home yet so i
cannot confirm anything about that it's
mostly watching it i may actually be in
the movie theater watching it so we'll
know soon but yelena texts kate that she
knows who hired her to kill clint and
that was eleanor bishop confirming that
val must work for eleanor and that
eleanor's partner in crime all this time
has been well that's the guy i've been
worried about this whole time
kingpin boom are you looking for
that sure is vincent d'onofrio wearing a
white jacket and sporting cane the
episode's credits credit to vince de
domino yes i know yeah all right i guess
at some point koi jon and i were talking
to each other looking and and then the
name came on screen and then we spent
the whole credits discussing how his
name didn't come on screen really showed
up twice many of you guys went way out
of your way to tell us in the comments
and then also
to
uh hit me up on social media some of you
tracked out my home knocked on my door
what do you guys keep it down out there
we all
know we get it thank you
there was no need to set my car on fire
and then put in fire words like batman
that fits into operations
here
who also tweeted confirmation quoting
his when i was a boy lying from the
netflix daredevil series as you
suspected based on the many clues the
laugh the cufflinks celebs gotta stop
spoiling [ __ ]
kingpin is of course the recurring
marvel villain to spider-man to
daredevil to many new york-based
characters and really there is no limit
to what upcoming mcu titles he could now
appear in most likely echo but perhaps
also armor wars or secret invasion i'm
seeing no way home soon so who knows
maybe there too kevin feige also
confirmed charlie cox daredevil would be
joining the mcu from the netflix side of
the universe as well in the past the
netflix shows would occasionally
reference the mcu in the battle of new
york but until now the official mcu
titles never once referenced the netflix
world or characters i'm not sure
every netflix marvel character is
automatically probably mcu canon since i
doubt disney plus would want to tell all
their viewers to spend hours and hours
catching up on seasons of story lines on
their rival netflix even though you
totally should because those shows are
pretty great rather we may be looking at
a kind of soft reboot in which these
versions of wilson fisk and matt murdock
are really variants in this universe the
mcu separate from the characters we were
left with at the end of daredevil season
3 on netflix they're still essentially
the same characters with the same
relationships just with a slightly
altered history that in this case ties
kingpin to the tracksuits back in 2007
and gives him some history with ronan
clint during the blip i go into all this
in another video you should check it out
i don't i feel like
i would
like that i feel like part of the big
part of the excitement is to bring to
keep a candidate to have the context the
reason why we're excited is the
brilliance of the context there
not
just the casting alone yeah revelation
this was all happening while all the
other mcu stuff was happening hey
like i will finally see them collide to
that effect like when i was re-watching
the spider-man movies and to be like oh
wow these events with doc ock from 2004
are now canon like the doc is now canon
to the mcu you know i offer molina
that's what makes it exciting they
didn't go these are just variants we
cast the same actors to play different
characters yeah for the same name and
likeness but then the credits go into
thorough ravenscroft's classic you're a
mean one mr grinch which is perfect for
a lonely jerk who glares down at us from
his tower it's also the kind of winky
villain theme that recalls the tone of
it's been agatha all along but it also
indicates that there may yet be a heart
in there two sizes too small buried
under all that bulk a heart attack
belongs to vanessa embarrassed me in
front of her
yeah that's the final shot of the great
sequence now includes the massive
silhouette of kingpin looming over clint
and kate in the city casting him as the
literal big bad that towers over the mcu
now this is the same kind of thing
but the celestials or even just a shape
in the sky always there always watching
like the watcher somehow of all of these
characters kingpin has me the most
terrified to support our channel check
out one of our great merch options
dibs
faster
that one you got the new spider-man one
always watching kingpin
i'm just gonna buy the variant colors of
everything you should get and wear them
on different days all right guys thanks
so much for watching follow new
rockstars it's all that matters keep a
lookout for finale to hawkeye episode
six epic hero shop yeah get some swag
all right let's go let's go go
spider-man